[Musique]
et pour terminer ce journal on retrouve
mélanie poké bonsoir de la rédaction de
tv 78 et pour votre coup de coeur
loisirs cette semaine mélanie c'est un
bond dans le passé que vous proposez oui
pantalons serrés blazer cintré mini jupe
imprimée des poids des rayures à
rambouillet on vit depuis un mois et les
années yéyé une manifestation organisée
par le lion's club de rambouillet et
pourquoi les années 60 vivien vallée
nous donne la réponse
les années yéyé
c'est des couleurs de la bonne humeur et
de la personnalité
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que tout est
un peu dans un cx il faut que ça soit
aérodynamique partout dans tous les sens
et là on retourne dans la joie de vivre
de ses cette époque là et la joie de
vivre mélanie ça va se conjuguer avec
différentes animations les prochains
week end vont être bien remplie mais
celui ci dès samedi 12 octobre c'est
prévu une animation sixties 13 italienne
il y aussi une vente aux enchères qui
est prévue le même jour là les
passionnés pourront peut-être s'offrir
une camaro des années 60 où une
chevrolet des animations au profit des
oeuvres du lion's club des précisions le
slogan c'est 60 jours d'animations sur
les années de 60 pour les plus de 60 ans
en difficulté alors notamment les
malades d'alzheimer
vous savez que lyon ce club a lancé les
centres d'accueil de jour alzheimer
il nous en avons à rambouillet ensuite
les personnes qui ont des problèmes de
vue un bibliothèque sonore la vue qui
baisse après 60 ans les handicaps
physiques et mentaux
alors la vente aux enchères est prévue à
14h à l'hôtel mercure de rambouillet
l'animation italienne elle c'est le
matin dans la galerie marchande du bel
air merci mélanie et pour connaître
d'autres idées de sorties il ya plein
d'autres choses encore dans les yvelines
votre émission 7,8 loisirs et c'est à
retrouver dans quelques minutes sur tv